let's check in with silver state schools
credit union the sponsors of this next
segment to see how they're giving gifts
to the community this holiday season
scott welcome back
thank you rocky i appreciate you having
me oh it's always good to see you we are
talking about happy times calendar we
need a happy times calendar more than
ever right now so let's talk about the
2022 edition
we sure do so every year silver state
schools credit union receives artwork
submissions and 13 winners are selected
to be showcased in our annual happy
times calendar event and in fact this
year silver state schools credit union
get ready for this rocky received over 2
000 entries
so that's that's a super amount and so
we're extremely grateful to all the
students who participated and also to
the art teachers uh for supporting this
yearly endeavor and uh so our 36th
annual 2022 happy times calendar is now
available and members can visit any one
of our 10 branch locations and request
one complimentary copy
and i just wanted to point out
additional copies are available for two
dollars each but it goes to a good cost
so if you're not a member or if you want
additional copies and you are remember
you can visit a branch and pick up a
copy of the calendar for two dollars
each and all proceeds from our happy
times calendar sales benefit are people
over profit foundation which goes to
education uh and and different uh uh
charitable goods within
the the greater nevada uh area so it's
it's always for a good cost so the
calendar is available while supplies
last wow i know that's gonna look good
on everybody's wall and i'm not i bet
this is a really happy time for you guys
it's the holidays you get to help people
um and give back to the community so
let's talk about holiday cash back
yeah exactly so i'm glad you mentioned
that too so silver state schools credit
union's amazing cash rewards credit card
program we will reward you every time
you use your credit card so this holiday
season members can earn 1.5 cash back
for every purchase every time
so that's going to allow you to shop
with confidence uh this holiday season
with service day schools credit unions
cash back rewards credit card and uh if
you want more details on that the
complete details are available by
visiting silverstatecu.com
and we're wrapping up your 70th
anniversary what's the update on that
we sure are so thank you i'm glad you
mentioned that to rocky in fact we're
good we're getting darn close to 71 now
so we're really excited about being made
the best credit union again this year
and that's a great tribute to our 70th
anniversary and you know it's really an
honor for silver state schools credit
union to serve our community for over 70
years and we're really thankful to our
members for voting us gold as best
credit union for the fourth straight
year so almost anyone can become a
member um and and be part of the silver
state schools credit union family and so
for more information please again visit
the silver silverstatecu.com
thank you silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring that segment give
them a call
702-733-8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com for more information
and remember that special offer members
can get 1.5 cash back for every purchase
using that cash back rewards credit card
with them all right happy
for this holiday season we'll be right
back